now that CS goes in everyone's rear view
mirror let's take a look at some of the
most annoying metas the creek Meadow was
[__] insane it was constantly used in
Pro and Casual play and it even survived
a price increase which usually fixes
these issues and you can say the same
thing about the OG that was also hell
but let's not forget the day the R8
revolver came out it was just broken it
could one shot anyone from the body at
close range and to my fellow nod head
clickers that's our kind of gun
somebody with a [__] pistol why is
that allowed and remember the tech 9 and
CZ metas when Force buying just made
sense God that was dumb then there's the
UMP meta that was just a snooze Fest I
still have beef with that butt cheeks of
a gun one thing that all of those metas
had in common they sucked and can stay
dead